from transgendered to trans abled guys
this is a real story now people are
choosing to identify as handicapped this
is not a joke onion story this is not an
onion story this is not a Babylon Beast
story this is a Fox news story
transablism or body Integrity identity
disorder can you actually Google this to
see if this is a real thing
I I D B I actually go copy paste and see
if something will come up biid okay it
is a societal issue in this is not a
this is Nia this is real this is not a
joke and it's a societal issue in which
individuals identify as handicapped and
may even ask doctors to amputate healthy
limbs snip sniper cords
spinal cords or destroy eyesight this
term has been relabeled to align with
the Trans Community with some Advocates
harnessing the cultural power of gender
ideology to cause of allowing doctors to
treat
biid patients
some people would be IID mutilate
themselves which is why culturally trans
ableism is being called the next Abyss
the National Institute of Health notes
that those with biid desire
for a desire amputations or paralysis
one North Carolina college student has
called transablism a cry for attention
and Arizona internist has labeled a
delusional disorder while some doctors
may be willing to perform procedures
these doctors have issues for
transablism most will only perform those
they feel are medically indicated
I don't I don't even know how to where
to start I can't I'm flabbergasted I
don't think I've ever used that word but
when are we as a society going to stop
pretending okay this isn't trans
ableism it's called it for what it is
it's trans stupidityism okay these
people have mental disorders okay
they're dying for attention and instead
of going out right there go being active
go go do something you're gonna cut your
lit like one lady she was on that Dr
Phil jet she poured acid in her eyes
she's sitting there looking that she
didn't know where the hell to look you
how do you think these people that are
actually handy what do you mean Port
acid on the right this lady Pat she want
she goes I was born and I identify I
wanted to be handicapped so she poured
acid in her eyes pan she went that lady
this lady that lady right there look at
her and then did you play this just play
for a second to see how she sounds
regrets about taking your own Vision or
the process with which you you did take
care of it look I don't have any regrets
taking my vision
I believe I should have been born blind
this is not a spoof
look at this little reaction about the
way I did it but I'm in the end I'm
happy like a transversion this is
unbelievable
look Dr Phillips
it's a really hard time sitting next to
this really hard time
sitting so close to someone who
traumatized herself who damaged herself
we took an oath in medicine to help
people we see horrible tragedies every
single day as doctors and people who
would give anything to go back and
restore their Vision their health Jesus
my heart is beating out of my chest I
can't even make sense of the emotions
I'm feeling because to hear someone say
I've always felt I should be blind well
I've always felt I should be the queen
of England but I'm not going out to
become
okay
[Music]
and listen I understand like listen
everybody here wants to park in the
handicapped spot but chopping off your
leg or doing this type of stuff to park
close to a building is absurd and Jen I
I said like a lot of this stems from
this whole movement the whole trance all
of it I think it started when
disciplining your children became taboo
because think about it if Pat be honest
if one day you're like you know what Dad
I'm I'm not I'm Patricia now what would
your father have done to you Pat be
honest with me what would Gabriel have
done and I'm being genuinely if you came
home to your dad was probably watching
and you said Papa you know what I have
Patrick this Patrick schmattric I want
to be Patricia what is your father and
you're dead serious what did your father
do to you I couldn't even tell you
because that thought is confusing for
for me to even think about you know I
mean I put I played a lot of great
pranks on the guys that you fell for
what but that this this is above that
though this is
like to to allow people to get to this
point okay so we're having this
conversation with my sister at the house
yeah okay we went out this weekend we're
watching the Blue Angels we had a great
time it was sick right but we're having
this conversation my sister
about uh lgbtq and the direction is gone
and transgender and all this other stuff
I think
you were parents are playing a very
slippery slope where they're kind of
like no it's okay you know do whatever
you want to do no no it's okay you know
to each his own no it's okay it's not to
each his own this person got three and a
half million views okay how many other
women see this kids and they're gonna be
like well I relate to this if I'm going
to get this much eyeballs and I'm
finally going to get some attention I'll
do something like this of course I'm
willing to do this to my body and if
they don't have love in their household
they don't have any encouragement in
their household nothing like that's
going to be happening kids are going to
make some stupid decisions with their
lives because of this people can't sit
on the sidelines and say the argument of
it's her choice let her do whatever she
wants to do with her body no you have to
have mental issues to be willing to do
something like this to yourself that has
to be clear and it can't be like sitting
aside and saying no I'm good with my
life I think I think the the lack of
calling out and calling out you
know a
insanity is causing a lot of people to
think this is the norm Dwayne Wade the
other day said I have to leave the state
of Florida because it just didn't match
my values and principles bye and we
decided to go to a different place where
our you know son daughter is it a son or
daughter now what is it now it's a guy
that wants to be a guy I'm confused I
don't know so but the point is we had to
leave the state of Florida okay well
good for you bro congratulations to
wherever else you moved to because you
are trying to protect your you know
transgender child now what are you going
to say if this 26 year old kid one day
this kid of yours one day is 26 and says
Dad why did you let me do that at 13
years old well what are you gonna do
well I don't know how old a kid is by
the way what are you going to do when
one day your kid says that why did you
let me go through that process I was
delusional at that time then what's your
argument going to be dad what are you
going to say then there's a lot of stuff
that kids will say to their parents and
15 year old now it's a 15 year old kid
just a lot of things that kids will say
to their parents we have to straight up
start calling out weird strange crazy
idea videos like this that were even
doing an episode today about trans
ableism what are your thoughts on this
jet well I mean what's interesting is
you see the audience reaction and we can
all be like look at the audience look at
the people on the channel they're all
horrified and my response is give it 10
years give it 10 years because you know
what 20 years ago if you had brought
somebody in that was a child that was on
you know all these hormone pills and
whatnot if you looked at mutilation that
people are doing in their own bodies
you know to I'm a girl I want to be a
boy this that people would have
commented on that in the same way would
have said well wait a minute this is
very concerning but now these same
people if you brought out what I just
said if you brought out people in the
trans community and whatnot these very
same people on the panel would be very
hesitant to say anything bad about that
so you have this like we're adjusting to
a new normal all the time and what you
have is a lot of people I mean this is
mental illness right 100 I mean 100
wrong either it's mental illness or it's
social contagion or it's a desire for
popularity and there's been a lot of
allegations against Mulvaney by the way
Dylan Mulvaney that people say who knew
him said oh this is all to get
popularity look at all the money that
Dill mulvania is making now there are
people that are willing to do anything
for money so I think there's a lot of
undiagnosed mental illness there's a lot
of normalization of mental illness
there's a lot of social Contagion on
social media where people who are lost
and struggling and maybe going through
some mental stuff on their own think
this is their way to find new oh this is
where I'm really gonna find my space
where I'm gonna be happy you see kids
being being manipulated heavily in those
spaces did you see did you see Duke
Health my sister just sent me this took
medicine opened its gender clinic in
2015 okay
and they offer a wide variety of
Services Under One Roof if you can find
this okay put Duke Medicine gender
Clinic Duke Medicine gender Clinic
uh right there so they offer a variety
of Services Under One Roof the clinic
treats children as young as two for
gender dysphoria yeah this is sickness
now I mean I have a three-year-old right
we saw I mean Duke University that's
right and that and that's the other
thing that people people don't take it
that extra step because again
these are the the American you know all
of these traditional medicine facilities
again I always bring in Pharma there's a
lot of cash cow here there's a lot of
money to be made off of lifelong
commitment to once you have a surgery
you have to take these hormones there's
so much formal money to be made here
that you're gonna have media endorsement
of strange things you're going to have
you know medical institutions that you
once deemed respectable and you were
like well this was a respectable
institution first of all was it and
secondly who do they report to what is
their end game there's a lot of money to
be made in this very very disturbing
stick stuff and who suffers people
mostly young young kids that are now
being roped into this I think there's a
lot of money under it when we look back
at this in five ten years you're going
to see the money lines be so clear I
mean this is Duke Duke used to be known
as slightly more conservative University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill was
slightly more liberal and but they
weren't enemies but they were kind of on
a spectrum like that Pat that was the
difference and at um I think it's
Flagler which was the MBA school at
Chapel Hill and then you had Fuqua Fuqua
which was the MBA school at Duke and it
was a little bit more conservative
actually a lot more conservative and now
you look and you see the med school
that's at Duke and it's really Stark
it's really those of us that know people
that 15 years ago 20 years ago graduated
either school I am shocked to see this
but I think there is I think there's a
money path here that's even bigger and I
agree with what has already been said
this is all about attention everybody
wants a box to check to get their
attention and to get their their Vibe
and you've got people that are doing
this for sport I think when it's I'd
love to see where villamovania is in 10
years five years and find out and find
out if he's back on the other side and
kind of jokes about the fact that he
cast the check so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire your podcast click right here
[Music]